welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition this is a dimension
as vast as space and as timeless as
infinity it is the middle ground between
not seeing the show and seeing it
it's the channel where we explain it so
you don't have to this is the twilight
zone
the show has just dropped it's 4th
episode in the Jordan Peele reboot and a
traveler like the mysterious character
in the episode definitely deserves a
look into throughout this video I'll be
breaking down everything that you need
to know about the show and it's ending
from here or now it's full spoilers
ahead so if you haven't seen it yet then
I highly recommend that you turn off now
with that out the way I hope you enjoyed
the video now sit back relax and let's
get into my ending explain breakdown of
a traveler the episode opens on
Christmas Eve and we join you care an
Alaskan state trooper as she pulls into
the station after busting her brother
which is a time-honored tradition whilst
the rest of her team appeared to be full
of Christmas joy UK is attempting to
keep her head down in the hopes of
having a relatively quiet night
every year the police captain pardons an
inmate in the holding cells to celebrate
the holiday and whilst it seems like
Yuka's brother will be an easy go to
things aren't as simple as they seem on
the surface after a mysterious star or
rather spaceship is seen above the
deputy office the strange man appears in
the cells and this episode centers
around discovering who exactly he is and
what his intentions are there's a cooler
I'll call back in the wrapping paper to
an episode called the dummy which sent
it around a ventriloquist dealing with
his apparently evil dummy
captain Pendleton could also be a
reference to Ellen Pendleton from the
episode known as the library in which
the character works in one which
possesses stories on everyone's lives
with terrifying accuracy there's also a
shot of a Christmas decoration that
looks like the doll from the living doll
episode and a callback to nightmare
20,000 feet with a gremlin and a similar
shot anyway back to this episode
a traveler played by Stephen Yin states
that he just wants to be pardoned and we
learned that he's known as an extreme
tourist and that he's traveled up to
Alaska as the pardoning parties a world
renowned and he wishes to be part of it
Yuuka senses something off about him and
there are clear shots towards Russia
throughout the episode which feel a bit
over the top especially with how much
social commentary that already is in the
show they basically say that the country
has never invented anything and steal
everything which yeah anyway Pendleton
overwhelmed by the idea of being famous
of course let's a traveler be the one
that is allowed to be pardoned and he's
paraded about the party as a famous
youtuber in the same way that my grandma
does every time around a house a
traveler aware that you could suspect
something is up keeps trying to taunt
her with the present that he's bought
for her which he promises is something
that she's always wanted for Christmas
tensions escalate at the party when the
power cuts and we discover that due to
an Air Force Base there have been
several power outages in the area which
causes arguments within the town
electorate to make matters worse upon
staying that they will pardon you cos
brother a traveler states that he
shouldn't be freed as he stole some
valuable tools and therefore should
remain confined the questioning that
arises from this causes a traveler to
reveal that he knows things about the
people from the town and he looks around
the room revealing in depth secrets
about them which causes the party to
break out into a fight over funding and
contract surrounding the base Pendleton
calls the party off but a traveler
remains to be questioned which is when
it's revealed that a traveler lied about
the tools and he's actually an
undercover agent here to unearth the
corruption in the town whilst they don't
believe a man escorting back to the
cells
a traveler hints that he's here for
Pendleton and that he and Yuko will be
working closely together soon Pendleton
claims he witnesses antenna coming out
of a travelers head but you could has
not believe this and a place heavily
into the episodes true meaning a
traveler reveals that due to the town's
lacking energy infrastructure attacking
it would be very easy and he states that
captain Pendleton has revealed this
weakness to Russian invaders and that
they are attacking soon and Pendleton
rushes out into the night to tip off his
friends and stop them from being exposed
by a traveler's forces in case you
hadn't guessed there this episode is
heavily based on the apparent fake news
that the Russian government spreaded
during the Trump election in the same
way that such reports got people to turn
on one another within America a traveler
uses lies and over exaggerations as well
as the allure
to make the characters and the episode
opposites the mayor fighting the people
is a clear demonstration of this and
it's very apparent that a traveler is
manipulating the police office to
destroy itself from the inside so that
the travelers species can invade the
area a traveler states that he's done
nothing but lie to you get and she
investigated all of them except for the
one thing that benefited her which
echoes Pendleton's hopeful fame when he
first arrived this again showcases that
people will only believe the truth that
they are willing to accept a traveler
tells UK that it's too late to do
anything about it but she defiantly
races out into the night to stop
Pendleton and break up the fights
happening amongst the citizens Yuka
holds Pendleton at gunpoint revealing
that the fact he's fled into the night
means that it must be true the two argue
back and forth is Pendleton state it's
only a lie if they choose to believe it
which is when spacecraft take over the
area and a traveler reveals his true
form Yuka's brother relaxes with the
alien and eats pie content with the fact
that they will be better rulers in the
end Yuka had the opportunity to stop the
entire event but was too caught up in
the moment and like many wanted power
and would believe anything that she was
told that would further this goal this
is a bit a sweet example of how we must
not get caught up in lies when making
decisions and how ultimately we are
easily fooled by deceit dressed up as
the truth it's probably my favorite
episode from the run this far and whilst
the Russian bashing is pretty
heavy-handed I still had a lot of fun
with this one
obviously I'd love to hear your thoughts
on the episode and if you're enjoying
the series so far make sure you comment
below and let me know and if you enjoyed
this video then please like it and make
sure you check out my breakdown of the
entire season thus far which will be
linked at the end this is the channel
for people who are never missing
television so if that's the kind of
thing you like you need to subscribe to
definition thanks again for taking the
time to watch this you've been the best
and I'll see you next time take care
peace
you